[Musique]
isabelle trouve des chaussettes de yoga
dans ce magasin d'articles de sport
l'éthique est sûre et chaussettes
indique 10 dollars pourtant rendu à la
caisse isabelle constate que le prix est
de 18 dollars comme il ya une erreur
dans le prix elle réclame que le
caissier lui laisse le produit
gratuitement en vertu de la politique
d'exactitude des prix selon cette
politique en cas d'erreur sur le prix
d'un article annoncé à 10 $ ou moins
le commerçant doit le remettre
gratuitement aux clients le caisson
refuse en disant que cette politique ne
s'applique pas à son commerce
et il a raison pourquoi à cause d'une
nuance qu'isabelle ignorait il y a deux
types de commerce de détail ce qui
appose une étiquette sur chacun des
articles qu'ils vendent et ceux qui
inscrivent le prix seulement sur la
tablette
or la politique d'exactitude des prix
s'applique uniquement aux commerces qui
inscrivent les prix sur la tablette
par contre dans un commerce comme celui
où se trouve isabelle le commerçant a
toujours l'obligation de lui laisser le
bien au prix étiqueté le fin mot de
l'histoire
faire respecter ses droits c'est bien
connaître la loire c'est mieux